it's one of those shows that when
everyone's coming up to me seeing have
you seen narcos have you seen stranger
things
have you seen the latest Game of Thrones
I'm like have you seen from dusk till
dawn then shut the [ __ ] up I'm just
joking but that is a real conversation I
find myself in lately
hello guys I am Greg Gregory Alba I had
a huge fan of the show from dusk till
dawn it's one of the few shows I've
actually seen as a place I'm such a big
fan that I bought tickets for this I
didn't get invited they didn't offer
this to me for free I bought tickets to
the pally Center Paley Center which
gentleman's here to correctly pronounce
that for me from dusk till dawn and the
cast is gonna be there rob rodriguez is
gonna be there I'm like it's such a cool
[ __ ] Joe Casey guys haven't seen it
season 3 is right around the corner for
those who have seen it let's check out
the season 3 trailer together and I'll
talk more about the show afterwards
Gekkos of course like an ass I talked
over the very beginning of the trailer
instead again
these are the legendary brothers
yeah Zayn holds a DJ controller so we're
trying to get to heaven if you believe
in heaven is their vehicle I suggest you
start to believe in him [ __ ] this is war
we have no idea what's coming next
Oh
whoa what the [ __ ]
Zack chain
Ranger
oh wait a minute was that is that the
guy who played that was the guy who
played sex machine right in the first
and then in the actual movie okay well
there's actually a sex machine there I
didn't notice that no way that's it it's
the how could I not remember same as the
makeup guy I worked on all those like
George Romero [ __ ] isn't it
we're in devote comes in handy people
Tom Savini it's [ __ ] Tom Savini
yeah oh [ __ ] oh damn he's like credited
in like most of the episodes of season 3
oh that's really excited that like they
even got Danny Trejo to play a totally
different character in season 2 when he
was in the original from dusk till dawn
Robert Patrick's a star from dusk till
dawn too and then he plays the role
harvey keitel play but in the show and
if you guys haven't seen this show like
if I were to do a review of the entire
show right now that would be such a long
review so I'll try to summarize it for
you right now the first season is
awesome okay it's especially awesome if
you've seen the actual movie granted you
don't need to see the first movie the
original film to like get the show but
there's a there's a lot of homage and
there's a lot of fan tribute to the
actual you know movie that Rob Rodriguez
first did first off let me tell you like
Robert Rodriguez directed a lot of the
episodes fede alvarez who did don't
breathe and the remake of Evil Dead he
directed a lot of the episodes there's
some really talented [ __ ] actors in
there man so in the first season it is
like a season this show based off the
whole film so like the first few minutes
are from dusk till dawn they essentially
flush that out in the whole first
episode so on and so forth and it which
is cool because they don't take away
upon
that made the movie so cool we're from
dusk till dawn the film was awesome in
the sense that the first half is this
getaway film and the second half are
like last 30 minutes is a vampire film
so they manage to honor that without
throwing too much vampire stuff in the
first half just enough so that way it's
not way to like [ __ ] weird because
it's a show it's different for a movie
but in a show you gotta like semi
prepare them for something like that to
happen what's great is it's it honors a
lot of the show you get way more
character background like the characters
here are I liked the show more than the
movie and I had seen the movie so many
times prior to watching the show and I
love this show much more because you
really do understand the characters more
this feels more like the world that Rob
Rodriguez didn't want to explore with
from dusk till dawn see in the movie
they don't explore the vampire world
really they're just the the creatures
that happened that like are there and
they're become the villains of the story
in the show it becomes so much about the
vampire world and that's what makes the
second season so great because in the
second season they get a break ties
completely of the actual movie source
material and they allow each character
to become their own their recur occurs
that I didn't even really care for in
the first season but when they got to
really do their own thing with them in
the in the second season I really liked
them and the characters I already liked
I loved what they did with them even
more like DJ cotrona man he is so
[ __ ] cool he's one sexy [ __ ]
have you seen this guy they've given us
characters that we can really care for
characters that we can really get to
know and the vampire world is so [ __ ]
cool you got great new characters and
they're Wilmer Valderrama who I thought
I'd have the hardest time seeing past
him you know doing like such a serious
role I grew to really like him
especially in the second season DJ
cotrona Seth gasser all that george
clooney played and Zane Holtz plays
Quentin Tarantino's role of Richie gecko
I really do love what they did with
those characters because in the movie
alone in that source material you don't
really love them as brothers you see
George Clooney's alright but Tarantino I
was like man this guy's [ __ ] up he
needs to be put down and George Clooney
just season kind of as like a
burden in a lot of ways in this show you
see you love the gecko brothers you want
the gecko brothers together they're
their best scenes are when they're
together and you really groped like they
managed to really get you to really like
Zayn Holtz's character I didn't come
close to liking Tarantino's character in
the movie and I think that's pretty
intentional but in this story the way
they evolved
everyone's character it's really cool
their vampire character they have
santanico ah she's she's beautiful to
look at and she's very talented too I
really like what they did with her
character because in the first season I
kind of felt like yeah they got a really
sexy actress cool in the second season I
really felt that like she needs to
really show off a lot more for acting
chops in that one I thought she did a
fantastic job I respect you as an
actress not just the good-looking person
the guy plays Scott uh Brandon sue who I
think is his name that did honestly
first season just like in the movie it
wasn't a fan of that actor and I wasn't
that big of a fan of his performance and
the first season knocking a lot in the
second season though I love that they
kept his character around because you
know if you watch the movie you know
there's the Fate he suffers but in the
show they really do a lot of it they
they take his character down a whole
other direction that makes them a lot
more interesting and a lot more fun to
watch I thought he did a fantastic job
same thing with the girl plays Kate
Madison Davenport I'm super stoked to
see what they're gonna do the way they
got some freaky [ __ ] in mind for her
character cuz dude that was a great way
to end season 2 with what you did there
folks if you haven't seen it he got to
go back and watch immediately just know
that Kate she's an important character
one of the additions to the show that I
really liked is Ranger Gonzalez full
disclosure
okay I have met this guy before and I've
talked to him a few times on Facebook
cuz when I first met him I only seen a
couple of the episodes that from dusk
till dawn many months after I met him I
Hey I decided to like you know I really
want to watch that show so started
watching it ended up loving it and I've
had a chance to tell him how great it is
and okay I wasn't gonna say see over
Facebook but Jesse Garcia first season I
thought you did a good job and I think
it's because I knew
you were I had a hard time seeing past
you that is my fault for you know just
knowing you having met you before I'm
being really aware of you the second
season though do do you kick [ __ ] ass
man like the way they change your
character brother that was like who they
turn Ranger Gonzalez into this like dark
hero is so [ __ ] cool
they make Ranger Gonzalez like the hero
of the show he's the really lucuma good
guy but he gets involved in the dark
[ __ ] he's the family man he's the guy he
has morals in the heart like Keith ah
yeah kick-ass role dude that's a
kick-ass role he's also the film
quinceañera I'm excited that Jake Busey
is coming back you take me easy man
I watched the frighteners I showed it to
John for the first time not that long
ago that dude is one creepy [ __ ]
but goddamn why is he so funny he's like
so creepy and so funny he's such a
unique gift man they honor the movie so
much but but especially what the way it
were season 2 goes by the end it's on
Netflix I'm encouraging you to binge
watch it that's what I'm not giving
anything away right now but when season
3 premieres I'll be more descriptive
about you know more up-to-date things as
far as it goes with season 3 the
underworld is encompasses the criminal
underworld and the vampire world which
essentially eight controls they like
most of the criminal underworld
it's a really badass show the writing is
great cinematography is [ __ ]
excellent the directing is fantastic
performance is all around really [ __ ]
cool there's some great violence and a
gripping store like it's an easy [ __ ]
show to binge watch anyway I just talked
about the shadow and I'm talking about
the season 3 trailer at this point in
the show where rich and Seth are really
out to become the kings of the
underworld and with other roles in here
too and then hearing about this new
villain they're introducing will really
show them what hell is like like season
2 gets [ __ ] batshit crazy in terms of
violence I feel like part 3 is gonna go
even more insane with the
lust it's a really fun show dude and if
you want to get in the Halloween spirit
and see like some recent work of film or
TV that really gives you a cool vampire
show you got to go watch the show
immediately join me at the Paley Center
that'd be fun
September 9th I believe I'll be there
and I hope that I don't get out too much
when I meet these guys if they let me
meet them I'm not the kind of guy to ask
questions in a QA I'm I keep hoping
someone just points to me and goes you
you look interesting what do you think I
am in no way getting paid to promote
this shuttle I have not paid anyone any
promises I have not said anything I feel
like I don't know enough people that
watch the show and I don't want more
people to watch the show so please go
watch it thank you i'm greg alba
subscribe goodbye